Today I wanted to try out a fun new makeup product.
This is the Tarte Blush and glow.
Um, has a bunch of different blushes and highlighters to give you, like,
all super glowy cheeks.
So I'm gonna do my base makeup,
and then we're gonna try some of these products out.
Now, I always keep a vintage flare to my makeup,
but as we get into the warmer months,
I definitely try and go with a glowier,
more, like, luminous skin.
So I'm really excited about this product.
Okay, I finished hair makeup,
and now we're gonna get into the cheeks.
Using. There's a couple different options.
So I think I'm gonna use this super pink one, and then this more,
like, neutral,
like, frosty highlight.
So the ones I'm gonna use are pink,
and pearl Glow has this really sweet little applicator,
so I'm just gonna put a couple dots up here.
Oh, that's really shimmery already.
That's really pretty.
See, on the other side,
you could use a brush to blend it out,
but I kind of always love using my fingers for cream products,
and that just gives, like,
a really pretty flush of color.
Like, nothing too crazy.
And add a little more just right here on the middle.
With a liquid product,
it's always good to start a little bit reserved and build,
because you never know how,
like, pigmented something's gonna be.
Okay, that is gorgeous.
Now to add a little bit more Highlight.
I'm gonna go in with this pearl color right up here,
and this is, like,
my favorite color for a highlight.
For me, it's, like, a neutral pearly white silver.
Gonna add a little to the top of my nose and, like,
right here.
Okay, that is truly.
That is glowing.
I love that. Okay,
so definitely,
definitely go ahead and try these.
I'm gonna try more of the
warmer colors when I get a little bit of tan going
here in the summer,
but these are fantastic products if you want that,
like,
very natural flesh,
like a perfectly ethereal cheek.